bienvenido de nuevo a "Entendiendo la información y computación cuántica", mi nombre es John Watrous y soy el director técnico de educación en IBM
Quantum. Esta es la lección 12 de la serie y es la última lección de la tercera unidad, que trata sobre la formulación general
de la información cuántica. Esta lección gira en torno a una noción fundamental en la información cuántica, que es la de una
purificación de un estado cuántico. Una purificación de un estado cuántico representado por alguna matriz de densidad es un
estado puro de un sistema compuesto más grande que nos deja con el estado original cuando el resto del sistema compuesto es
descartado o trazado. Toda matriz de densidad tiene una purificación y podemos aprender mucho
sobre los estados cuánticos y sobre la información cuántica en general estudiando purificaciones. A nivel intuitivo,
los vectores de estado cuántico, que representan estados puros, son objetos matemáticos más simples que las matrices de densidad, y al pensar en
purificaciones de estados, podemos ver los estados cuánticos arbitrarios de los sistemas como simples partes de algo más grande pero
más simple. También hablaremos sobre la fidelidad entre dos estados cuánticos, que es un valor que cuantifica su
similitud o solapamiento, y se usa frecuentemente como forma de medir qué tan bueno es un estado particular en comparación con
algún estado ideal. En particular, discutiremos la definición de fidelidad junto con algunas de sus propiedades básicas, y veremos
cómo la fidelidad se conecta con las purificaciones. Aquí hay un resumen de la lección: empezaremos con las purificaciones, incluyendo la
definición y una prueba simple de su existencia, que nos dice cómo encontrar una cuando la necesitemos. Luego discutiremos algo conocido
como la descomposición de Schmidt de un vector de estado cuántico de dos sistemas, y veremos cómo las descomposiciones de Schmidt se relacionan con
las purificaciones. Luego discutiremos una relación de importancia crítica entre cualesquiera dos purificaciones del mismo estado, conocida como la equivalencia unitaria
de las purificaciones, y finalmente repasaremos algunos ejemplos. Después pasaremos a la fidelidad,
incluyendo su definición y algunas de sus propiedades básicas. Hablaremos sobre el Lema de medición suave, que es un hecho muy
útil que vincula la fidelidad con las mediciones, y finalmente, para concluir la lección, pasaremos al teorema de Uhlmann, que
establece una conexión fundamental entre la fidelidad y las purificaciones. Empecemos con la
definición de purificación. Una purificación de un estado, que asumimos está representado por una
matriz de densidad, es un estado puro de un sistema compuesto más grande que deja el estado original con el que empezamos cuando el resto
del sistema compuesto es trazado. Podemos expresar esto de forma más precisa en términos matemáticos de la siguiente
manera: si tenemos un sistema X que está en algún estado rho, es decir, rho es una matriz de densidad que representa un estado de X,
y S es un vector de estado cuántico de un par de sistemas XY tal que trazar Y del estado puro deja
rho, entonces decimos que S es una purificación de rho. Naturalmente, los nombres no importan;
podemos nombrar nuestros sistemas y estados como queramos, y el orden de los sistemas tampoco importa. Por ejemplo,
si el sistema Y estuviera a la izquierda en lugar de a la derecha, pero todo lo demás fuera igual, seguiríamos refiriéndonos a ese estado como una purificación de rho. Pero
nos quedaremos principalmente con esta configuración durante el resto de la lección, por simplicidad. Y lo primero que hay que decir
sobre la definición es que las purificaciones siempre existen para toda matriz de densidad rho. Para ser más precisos, toda
matriz de densidad rho tiene una purificación como describe la definición, siempre que el sistema Y sea al menos tan grande como X, es decir,
que Y tenga al menos tantos estados clásicos como X. La noción de purificación y
el hecho de que las purificaciones siempre existen resulta ser de importancia crítica, y también es parte de lo que hace bella la información cuántica, y espero poder
convencerte de ese hecho al final de la lección. Ahora demostremos que toda matriz de densidad tiene una purificación, y en
el proceso veremos cómo obtener una purificación cuando la necesitemos. Igual que en la definición,
supongamos que X es un sistema y rho es una matriz de densidad que representa un estado de
X. Considera ahora cualquier expresión de rho como una combinación convexa de estados puros, como tenemos escrito en pantalla. En palabras,
para alguna elección de un entero positivo n, tenemos un vector de probabilidades p₀ hasta pₙ₋₁, así como vectores de estado cuántico
φ₀ hasta φₙ₋₁, y al promediar los estados puros correspondientes ponderados por las probabilidades
obtenemos rho. Por ejemplo, podríamos usar el teorema espectral para obtener una expresión de rho así, y si lo hiciéramos
podríamos tomar n como el número de estados clásicos de X. De hecho, podríamos tomar n como el rango de rho, que es
igual al número de valores propios no nulos de rho, contando cada uno un número de veces igual a su multiplicidad, y
eso nunca es mayor que el número de estados clásicos de X, aunque podría ser menor. Por otro lado, esto no
tiene que ser una descomposición espectral de rho, y no necesitamos que estos vectores de estado cuántico sean ortogonales. Por ejemplo, cualquier expresión de rho así
es válida. Y aquí hay una purificación de rho: la suma recorre los mismos valores que
en nuestra expresión de rho, y dentro de la suma tomamos las raíces cuadradas de las probabilidades multiplicadas por φₐ tensorizado
con |a⟩. Aquí, por cierto, asumimos que 0 hasta n menos uno son estados clásicos del segundo sistema Y, así que
tiene sentido que S sea un vector de estado cuántico del par XY, como en la definición. En realidad no es importante
aquí usar estados de la base estándar de Y en esta expresión; podrías sustituir cualquier colección ortonormal de
estados en lugar de |0⟩ hasta |n−1⟩ si quisieras. Y ahora podemos verificar que esto es efectivamente
una purificación calculando la traza parcial sobre Y. Aquí hay una expresión del estado que obtenemos al realizar la traza parcial.
La traza de |a⟩⟨b| es uno o cero dependiendo de si a es igual a b o no, por lo que la expresión
se simplifica a nuestra expresión original de rho. Y es así de simple. Así que es muy fácil obtener una
purificación, siempre que tengamos suficientes estados clásicos de Y o, alternativamente, un conjunto ortonormal suficientemente grande para usar en
lugar de los estados de la base estándar |0⟩ hasta |n−1⟩. Por cierto, si el número de
estados clásicos de Y es menor que el rango de rho, entonces no habrá purificación, y te dejo eso
para que lo pienses si quieres. Aquí hay un ejemplo: consideremos
la matriz de densidad que vimos varias veces en la lección sobre matrices de densidad. Aquí tenemos una expresión de esta
matriz de densidad como combinación convexa de estados puros. No es una descomposición espectral, pero no nos
importa. Y con casi ningún esfuerzo podemos escribir una purificación del estado siguiendo la
receta. Esa no es la única purificación de esta matriz de densidad; las purificaciones no son únicas, pero está bien.
La definición no dice nada sobre unicidad, y de hecho hay una relación muy interesante entre las distintas purificaciones del mismo estado, pero
lo discutiremos un poco más adelante en la lección. A continuación consideraremos las descomposiciones de Schmidt, que son expresiones de
vectores de estado cuántico bipartitos en cierta forma que describiré en un momento. Llevan el nombre de Erhard
Schmidt, el mismo Schmidt conocido por el procedimiento de ortogonalización de Gram-Schmidt. Pero en el caso de las descomposiciones de Schmidt, probablemente no deberían
llevar el nombre de Schmidt; es matemáticamente equivalente a algo llamado descomposición en valores singulares para matrices, que es algo que fue
redescubierto múltiples veces, pero eso pasa a veces. De todas formas, esto es lo que queremos decir
cuando hablamos de una descomposición de Schmidt: para cualquier elección de un vector de estado cuántico S de un par de
sistemas XY, siempre es posible escribir S en una forma especial. Esa forma es la que
tenemos aquí en pantalla, donde R es algún entero positivo, p₀ hasta pᵣ₋₁ son números reales positivos que
juntos forman un vector de probabilidades, x₀ hasta xᵣ₋₁ son vectores unitarios correspondientes al sistema X, e y₀
hasta yᵣ₋₁ son vectores unitarios correspondientes al sistema Y. Eso puede que no parezca particularmente
especial hasta que te diga que ambos conjuntos x₀ hasta xᵣ₋₁ e y₀ hasta yᵣ₋₁ deben ser
ortonormal, y ¿por qué eso es especial? Bueno, si eligiéramos cualquier base para una de las dos bases, digamos
los vectores X que corresponden al sistema X, siempre podríamos expresar s en esta forma, y eso nos obligaría a
seleccionar los vectores Y de una manera particular. De hecho, hacemos esto de forma bastante rutinaria, como con una base estándar cuando estamos
preparándonos para analizar una medición en base estándar. Pero en general, incluso si elegimos una base ortonormal para los vectores X,
los vectores Y que obtenemos no necesariamente serán ortonormales. De manera similar, si elegiste una base
ortonormal para los vectores Y e intentaste expresar s en esa forma de nuevo, podrías hacerlo, pero de nuevo los vectores X no
necesariamente serían ortonormales. Y finalmente, si eligieras vectores ortonormales para ambos sistemas y
intentaras expresar s en una forma como esta, no necesariamente funcionaría, porque podrías necesitar algunos términos cruzados. Pero solo hay un
índice en esta suma, que es a, por lo que la forma es especial. Pero siempre es posible
escribir un vector unitario s dado de esta manera, y así es como puedes hacerlo: primero calcula una descomposición espectral
para el estado reducido de cualquiera de los dos sistemas. No importa cuál, pero para describir cómo se hace, veamos el estado reducido del
sistema X. Así que estamos trazando y, lo que significa que p 0 hasta p r menos uno son valores
propios de este estado reducido rho, y x0 hasta xR menos uno son vectores propios unitarios correspondientes a estos valores propios. Y
la comprensión aquí es que estamos ignorando los términos para los cuales los valores propios son cero, porque esos términos no aportan nada a la
suma. Es decir, p 0 hasta p r menos uno son todos números reales positivos, y R es el número de
valores propios no nulos contando multiplicidades, lo cual es igual al rango de rho. Eso nos da p 0 hasta p r
menos uno, así como x0 hasta xR menos uno. Y lo único que queda es encontrar los vectores y0 hasta y R menos
uno. Solo hay una elección que puede funcionar: esos vectores están determinados de forma única en este punto y pueden
encontrarse fácilmente usando la fórmula simple que se muestra en la pantalla. Y lo increíble aquí es que
si definimos estos vectores de esta manera, se garantiza que serán ortonormales, y eso nos da una descomposición de Schmidt. No lo argumentaré en este
video, pero no es demasiado difícil y puedes consultar el material escrito de la lección si te interesa. Revisa
la descripción del video para encontrar un enlace, como siempre. Como ejemplo, consideremos este
vector de estado cuántico, que obtuvimos como purificación del ejemplo de matriz de densidad al que seguimos volviendo.
No es una descomposición de Schmidt porque los estados cero y más no son ortonormales, pero podemos encontrar una
usando el procedimiento que acabo de describir. El primer paso es calcular una descomposición espectral para el estado redu
cido de X, que es ese mismo ejemplo de matriz de densidad. Y aquí hay una descomposición espectral del mismo, que vimos
en la lección 9. Así que elegimos p 0, P1, x0 y X1 tal como
se muestra en la pantalla. p 0 y P1 son los valores propios de rho, y x0 y X1 son
los vectores propios unitarios correspondientes. Así que queda calcular y0 e y1, y si lo hacemos, obtenemos ket más
para y0 y -1 * ket menos para y1. Eso no es inmediato, tienes que
hacer realmente el cálculo para verlo, pero eso es lo que obtenemos. Y como era de esperar, esos dos vectores son ortonormales, como
lo serán siempre si hiciste los cálculos correctamente. Y eso nos da una descomposición de Schmidt.
Las descomposiciones de Schmidt son muy útiles en muchas situaciones y pronto veremos qué nos dicen
sobre las purificaciones. Las purificaciones no son únicas: un estado cuántico dado representado
por una matriz de densidad tendrá de hecho infinitas purificaciones. Sin embargo, existe una estrecha
relación que siempre se mantiene entre dos purificaciones cualesquiera del mismo estado, y a veces se denomina la
equivalencia unitaria de purificaciones. Así es como funciona: sea rho una matriz de densidad
que representa un estado cuántico de un sistema X, y supongamos que tenemos dos purificaciones cualesquiera de ese estado que son
estados puros del mismo sistema compuesto. Para ser más concretos, supongamos que s y fi
son vectores de estado cuántico de un par de sistemas XY que ambos nos dan rho cuando el sistema Y es trazado
hacia afuera. Lo que dice la equivalencia unitaria de purificación es que debe existir una operación unitaria U que actúa solo sobre
el sistema y que transforma s en fi. En otras palabras, aunque estas son
purificaciones arbitrarias de rho y no asumimos nada sobre ellas excepto que ambas purifican rho y que son
ambas estados del mismo sistema compuesto XY, tienen que ser equivalentes en algún sentido, salvo una operación unitaria sobre y
solamente. Veremos algunos ejemplos que ilustran por qué esto es interesante y qué implicaciones tiene, pero primero
veamos por qué es verdad. Empecemos con una descomposición espectral de rho, que es la
matriz de densidad que tanto s como fi purifican. Y al igual que hicimos cuando discutimos la descomposición de Schmidt, vamos a
suponer que hemos descartado todos los términos correspondientes a valores propios cero. Así que p 0 hasta p r menos 1
son todos números reales positivos, x0 hasta xR menos uno son vectores propios ortonormales de rho, y R resulta ser el
rango de rho. Y por cierto, como nota aparte, fíjate con qué frecuencia recurrimos al teorema espectral en este punto.
Es una herramienta increíblemente útil y, de hecho, estaríamos perdidos sin ella. En fin, ahora que tenemos una descomposición
espectral de rho, podemos calcular descomposiciones de Schmidt de nuestros dos vectores, igual que antes. Y van a ser
casi exactamente iguales: los coeficientes y los vectores X son los mismos porque provienen de la descomposición espectral del estado reducido, que
es el mismo para ambos vectores. La única diferencia es que podemos obtener vectores distintos para el segundo sistema. Para
el primer vector, que es s, obtendremos un conjunto de vectores y0 hasta y R menos uno, y para el segundo vector, que es f, obtendremos
una colección posiblemente distinta que podemos llamar z0 hasta zR menos uno. Así que ahora tenemos descomposiciones de Schmidt
para nuestros dos vectores que se ven muy similares, excepto que los vectores para el segundo sistema pueden ser diferentes. Pero estas
son descomposiciones de Schmidt, por lo que estas dos colecciones son ambas ortonormales. Así que simplemente podemos elegir
una matriz unitaria U que envíe ya a Za para cada a. Siempre puedes hacer eso: las operaciones
unitarias son de hecho equivalentes a mapas lineales que transforman una base ortonormal en otra. Y si
estos dos conjuntos no abarcan todo el espacio correspondiente a Y, siempre podemos extenderlos ambos a bases
ortonormales usando, coincidentemente, el procedimiento de ortonormalización de Gram-Schmidt. Y así es como se prueba la
equivalencia unitaria de purificaciones. En la lección cuatro de la serie discutimos el protocolo de codificación superdensa,
que permite a un emisor transmitir dos bits clásicos a un receptor enviando un qubit al costo de un ebit de
entrelazamiento compartido. Así que asumo que ya estás familiarizado con ese protocolo. El objetivo de este ejemplo es explicar brevemente
cómo se conecta con la equivalencia unitaria de purificaciones. Recuerda que la manera en que
funciona el protocolo es que Alice y Bob comparten un ebit, o en otras palabras, un estado de Bell fi más. Alice elige transformar ese
estado de Bell en cualquiera de los cuatro estados de Bell, dependiendo de los dos bits que quiere enviar. Luego ella envía su
qubit a Bob y él mide para ver qué estado de Bell tiene. Nota que los cuatro estados de Bell
nos dan el mismo estado reducido para el qubit de Bob, que es el estado completamente mezclado. Y de hecho eso ya es suficiente
para concluir que la codificación superdensa es posible: los cuatro estados de Bell purifican el estado completamente mezclado, así que por la equivalencia unitaria
de purificaciones sabemos que debe ser posible para Alice transformar el estado de Bell fi más en cualquiera
de los otros aplicando alguna operación unitaria a su qubit. Por supuesto, no es difícil encontrar operaciones unitarias que
realmente funcionan y son muy simples, pero es interesante de todas formas que podamos llegar a la conclusión de que esto es
posible sin siquiera pensar en las operaciones unitarias en sí mismas, y además podemos concluir
que las generalizaciones del superdense coding a sistemas más grandes son posibles, siempre que tengamos alguna forma de generalizar los estados de Bell a sistemas más
grandes, de modo que todos produzcan el estado completamente mixto como el estado reducido de Bob, y de hecho hay distintas formas conocidas de hacer
eso. Otro contexto en el que la equivalencia unitaria de las purificaciones tiene implicaciones es la computación cuántica
criptografía, y una de sus implicaciones más importantes es que descarta la existencia de un protocolo cuántico incondicionalmente seguro para una
primitiva criptográfica conocida como bit commitment. ¿Qué es el bit commitment? El bit commitment es un ejemplo
de una primitiva criptográfica, con lo que queremos decir una tarea o procedimiento de bajo nivel que proporciona alguna funcionalidad básica,
que luego puede usarse como bloque de construcción para hacer cosas más interesantes, como crear esquemas de firma digital o construir
protocolos de conocimiento cero. En el caso del bit commitment, la funcionalidad básica es que un
jugador, Alice, puede comprometerse con un valor binario de su elección ante un segundo jugador, Bob, pero su elección permanece oculta
hasta que ella decide revelarlo. Requerimos dos propiedades específicas de un protocolo que implemente el bit
commitment: debe ser vinculante, lo que significa que Alice no puede cambiar de opinión una vez que se ha comprometido con un bit, y debe
ser ocultante, lo que significa que Bob no puede determinar el bit de Alice hasta que ella decida revelarlo.
Sería muy bueno poder implementar esta primitiva usando información cuántica, porque es una
primitiva útil, pero sin suposiciones adicionales resulta ser imposible hacerlo perfectamente con información cuántica, o incluso de forma aproximada,
y la equivalencia unitaria de las purificaciones revela que la idea, a un nivel muy alto, es
que si existiera un protocolo cuántico para el bit commitment, entonces tendría que haber una versión purificada de ese protocolo en la que podamos imaginar que
Alice tiene un sistema A, Bob tiene un sistema B, y tras el compromiso pero antes de que Alice revele, el par AB está en
uno de dos estados puros, psi cero o psi uno, dependiendo del bit al que Alice
se compromete. Si el protocolo es perfectamente ocultante, entonces Bob no puede distinguir entre los
dos compromisos, por lo que su estado reducido debe ser el mismo para las dos posibilidades. Sin embargo, eso implica, por
la equivalencia unitaria de las purificaciones, que Alice puede transformar cualquiera de los dos en el otro aplicando alguna operación unitaria
solo a A. Por tanto, el protocolo falla completamente en ser vinculante. Hay detalles que
he pasado por alto, pero el núcleo del asunto es que la equivalencia unitaria de las purificaciones nos dice que esta primitiva no es algo
que podamos implementar de forma fiable usando información cuántica sin suposiciones adicionales de algún
tipo. El último ejemplo de una implicación de la equivalencia unitaria de las purificaciones es un teorema conocido como el
teorema de Hughston, Jozsa y Wootters, o teorema HJW para abreviar. Comencemos con el enunciado del
teorema en sí, que es una versión ligeramente simplificada para evitar algunos tecnicismos y poder centrarnos en las ideas principales.
Supongamos que X e Y son sistemas y F es cualquier vector de estado cuántico que representa un estado puro del par
XY. Supongamos ahora que pensamos en el estado reducido del sistema X por sí solo y encontramos cualquier forma en que
elijamos expresar este estado reducido como una combinación convexa de estados puros, tal como se muestra en la pantalla.
Por ejemplo, el número N mayúscula en esta expresión, que es el número de estados puros sobre los que promediamos, podría
ser arbitrariamente grande, posiblemente mucho mayor que la dimensión del espacio correspondiente a X o a Y.
Lo que el teorema nos dice es que debe existir una medición sobre el sistema Y con N resultados, tal que
ocurra lo siguiente: cuando se mide el sistema Y, en primer lugar cada resultado de la medición
aparece con probabilidad exactamente igual a la probabilidad correspondiente en nuestra expresión del estado reducido de X como
combinación convexa de estados puros, y en segundo lugar, condicionado a obtener un resultado de medición particular,
el estado de X pasa a ser el estado puro correspondiente de la combinación convexa. ¿Por qué es
interesante eso? Significa que para cualquier forma en que elijamos pensar en el estado reducido de X como una combinación convexa
de estados puros, existe alguna medición de Y que hace que esta forma de pensar en el estado reducido de X sea una
realidad. Y lo notable es que esto es posible incluso cuando el estado F se elige primero y la combinación convexa
se elige después, siempre que sea una expresión del estado reducido de X, habrá una
medición de Y que funcione exactamente así. Veamos entonces cómo podemos demostrar
esto. Comenzamos con dos expresiones distintas para el estado reducido de X, al que daremos el nombre rho por
comodidad. A continuación, introducimos un nuevo sistema Z cuyos estados clásicos son los posibles resultados de la medición, o
equivalentemente, los índices en nuestra combinación convexa. Ahora podemos observar que los siguientes dos vectores de estado cuántico
gamma 0 y gamma 1, que son ambos vectores de estado para el sistema compuesto XYZ, son
ambos purificaciones de rho. Y para ser claros, cuando pensamos en estos vectores como purificaciones de rho, estamos
pensando en los sistemas Y y Z juntos como un único sistema compuesto que se traza para dejar
rho. El primer vector gamma 0 es esencialmente lo mismo que el estado puro original fi, excepto que estamos
inicializando el nuevo sistema Z al estado cero. Está claro que si trazamos Y y Z nos quedará rho, por lo que gamma
0 es una purificación de rho. El segundo vector gamma 1 es básicamente el vector que obtenemos al purificar
rho a partir de la combinación convexa, tal como describí antes en la lección. Esta vez el sistema Y está
inicializado, y supongo por simplicidad que cero es un estado clásico de Y, pero podrías sustituir cualquier
estado de base estándar, o de hecho cualquier estado puro de Y, en esta expresión sin que cambiara nada. En cualquier caso, al trazar Y y
Z nos queda rho. La conclusión es que ambos son purificaciones de rho, y por tanto, por
la equivalencia unitaria de las purificaciones, existe una operación unitaria U sobre el par YZ que transforma gamma 0 en
gamma 1, y eso es todo lo que necesitamos para obtener una descripción de una medición que haga lo que el teorema
dice. Una forma sencilla de describirlo es con un diagrama de circuit como el que se muestra aquí en la pantalla. En palabras, comenzamos con el
estado F, introducimos Z inicializado al estado cero, aplicamos U y luego medimos el sistema superior, que es Z, con una
medición en la base estándar. Lo que esto hace efectivamente es transformar fi en gamma uno, y
simplemente inspeccionando la descripción de gamma 1 podemos ver que esto hace lo que el teorema afirma: obtenemos
cada resultado a con probabilidad pa, y condicionado a obtener a, el sistema X queda en el estado sa.
Y para ser claros, la medición cuya existencia implica el teorema está implementada por
todo lo que hay dentro del rectángulo de puntos en la figura. Y si quieres saber cómo puede
describirse la medición como una colección de matrices, aquí tienes una expresión de ellas. No voy a explicar esta parte, y
no es realmente importante para el ejemplo, pero ahí está la expresión de las matrices de medición por si te
interesa. A continuación hablaremos de la Fidelidad, que es una medida de cuán similares son dos estados cuánticos, o alternativamente, cuánto
se solapan. Empezaremos con la definición, que puede parecer un poco misteriosa a
primera vista, pero la iremos descifrando, y al final de la discusión espero haberte convencido de que es
en realidad una función mucho más elegante de lo que podría parecer a simple vista. Aquí está la
definición: la Fidelidad entre dos matrices de densidad rho y sigma es igual a la traza de la raíz cuadrada de la
raíz cuadrada de rho multiplicada por sigma, por la raíz cuadrada de rho. Hablaremos sobre
primero intentemos entender la definición en sí: tenemos tres raíces cuadradas y
todas se refieren a la raíz cuadrada de una matriz semidefinida positiva, que como vimos en la lección anterior es
la única matriz semidefinida positiva que al cuadrado nos da la matriz de la que estamos tomando la raíz, porque
rho es una matriz de densidad, debe ser semidefinida positiva, así que podemos calcular su raíz, y si pensamos en la raíz de rho *
Sigma por la raíz de rho por un momento, vemos que también es semidefinida positiva y en particular podemos escribirla como
M† * M siendo M la raíz cuadrada de Sigma por la raíz cuadrada de rho, y por lo tanto podemos calcular la raíz
cuadrada de ella; en particular podemos calcular una descomposición espectral de la raíz de
rho * Sigma * la raíz de rho, y para obtener la raíz cuadrada solo necesitamos tomar las raíces cuadradas de los valores propios
y dejar los vectores propios sin cambios, y finalmente calculamos la traza de
esta matriz, y como la traza es igual a la suma de los valores propios, obtenemos la expresión que tenemos aquí
así que eso probablemente es algo que no querrías calcular a mano en general, y esta explicación quizás no
aporte mucha intuición sobre la Fidelidad ni por qué nos importa, pero con suerte aclara el significado técnico
de la fórmula. Por cierto, como apunte adicional, a veces la gente define la Fidelidad como
el cuadrado de la función que he definido aquí, y se refieren a esta función como la raíz
de la Fidelidad. La verás definida de ambas maneras, lo cual ciertamente puede causar confusión, pero normalmente no la causa
porque la gente suele ser bastante cuidadosa en dejar claro qué definición está usando, y tú deberías
asegurarte de hacer lo mismo. En mi opinión, realmente no hay una definición correcta ni incorrecta; yo la defino
así simplemente porque me acostumbré a hacerlo de esta manera, y sí encuentro que es un poco más conveniente, supongo porque prefiero elevar al cuadrado
algo y luego tomar la raíz cuadrada más adelante cuando sea necesario, pero por supuesto eres libre de tomar tu propia
decisión. De todos modos, déjame volver a la Fidelidad tal como está definida aquí: hay otras formas equivalentes de
definir la Fidelidad, y en ese sentido es una función bastante notable, y de hecho puede caracterizarse de maneras bastante interesantes
Aquí hay una manera bastante directa de reescribir la definición en términos de la norma traza, que vimos al final de
la lección anterior. No entré en demasiados detalles sobre la norma traza y en particular no
la definí para matrices no hermitianas, pero tiene una definición suficientemente simple: una forma de definir la norma traza de una
matriz arbitraria M es que es la traza de la raíz cuadrada de M * M†, o equivalentemente la traza de la raíz
cuadrada de M† por M; obtienes el mismo valor de cualquier manera, y podemos usar esa definición para simplificar la
definición de la Fidelidad como tenemos aquí abajo en la pantalla, y eso es útil porque revela que
es simétrica en los dos argumentos. También podemos expresar la norma traza de una matriz cuadrada M como el
máximo del valor absoluto de la traza de M * U, variando sobre todas las matrices unitarias U, lo cual no es obvio pero es
verdad, y eso nos da otra expresión para la Fidelidad. Así que aquí tenemos tres
definiciones equivalentes de la Fidelidad, y eso es solo el comienzo: hay varias otras definiciones equivalentes,
y veremos una especialmente importante que proviene del teorema de Uhlmann hacia el final de la lección
Bien, eso está muy bien, pero ¿qué significa todo esto a nivel intuitivo y por qué debería importarnos esta
función? Para responder estas preguntas, es útil considerar el caso especial en el que al menos uno de los dos
matrices de densidad representa un estado puro. Si ambos estados son puros, entonces la
Fidelidad es simplemente el valor absoluto del producto interno entre los dos vectores de estado cuántico, y en cierto modo
esta es una motivación principal para la Fidelidad misma: el valor absoluto del producto interno entre dos vectores de estado cuántico
siempre es un número entre cero y uno, y nos da una forma natural de medir cuánto solapamiento hay
entre dos vectores de estado cuántico. Puedes pensar en la Fidelidad como una forma útil y bien comportada de
extender esta manera de medir el solapamiento desde los estados puros a las matrices de densidad. Si uno de los estados es puro
y el otro no necesariamente lo es, entonces de nuevo tenemos una expresión simple para la Fidelidad, lo cual puede ser bastante
útil, y esa expresión se muestra aquí. La Fidelidad tiene muchas propiedades interesantes
y esa es una de las razones por las que la gente la usa: tiene una definición que no es realmente
tan elegante, pero es una función muy útil de todas formas, y a menudo es muy fácil de usar en parte gracias a sus muchas
propiedades asombrosas. Así que echemos un vistazo a algunas de ellas, comenzando con la observación de que la Fidelidad entre dos matrices de densidad
siempre es un número entre 0 y 1. Es cero si y solo si los estados
son ortogonales, lo que significa que las imágenes son subespacios ortogonales, o equivalentemente que el producto de las dos matrices es
cero, y la Fidelidad es uno si y solo si las dos matrices de densidad son iguales. Todo otro caso está en algún punto intermedio
pero intuitivamente hablando, cuanto más cercana a uno esté la Fidelidad, más similares son los estados, o alternativamente
mayor es su solapamiento. La Fidelidad también es simétrica; lo mencioné hace unos momentos, es
bastante claro a partir de la expresión que vimos para la Fidelidad en términos de la norma traza, pero es algo importante de reconocer
de todas formas. A continuación, la Fidelidad es multiplicativa para estados producto, lo que significa que la Fidelidad entre dos
estados producto siempre es igual al producto de las fidelidades entre los estados
individuales. Aquí hay una propiedad realmente útil: si tenemos cualesquiera dos matrices de densidad del mismo tamaño
junto con cualquier canal que tome estas matrices de densidad como entrada, la Fidelidad solo puede aumentar cuando ese canal
se aplica a ambos estados. En otras palabras, en términos de la Fidelidad, los canales solo pueden hacer que los estados
se vuelvan más similares entre sí, no pueden hacerlos menos similares. Y finalmente, para esta lista al menos,
hay una relación bastante estrecha entre la Fidelidad y la distancia traza entre estados, que se define
como la mitad de la norma traza de la diferencia entre las dos matrices de densidad. La distancia traza entre dos
estados se relaciona fuertemente con qué tan bien podemos distinguirlos, lo que discutimos en la lección anterior en el contexto de
la discriminación de estados y el teorema de Helstrom-Holevo, mientras que la Fidelidad cuantifica cuánto se solapan dos estados
Así que aunque no son exactamente lo mismo, no es sorprendente que haya una relación entre estas
dos cantidades. En cualquier caso, estas desigualdades, que típicamente se llaman las desigualdades de Fuchs-van de Graaf, hacen
esta relación matemáticamente precisa, y es bastante importante que aquí no hay absolutamente ninguna dependencia del tamaño del sistema del que estamos hablando
Podemos ver esta relación con un poco más de claridad con la ayuda de una figura. Si tenemos dos estados y
situamos la distancia traza entre ellos en el eje x y la Fidelidad en el eje y, entonces las correspondientes líneas verticales
y horizontales deben intersectarse en algún lugar dentro de esta región gris. La región más interesante
de la gráfica, por cierto, al menos desde el punto de vista práctico, es la esquina superior izquierda de la región gris; en particular cuando la
distancia traza es muy pequeña, la Fidelidad debe estar muy cercana a uno, y viceversa
Estas desigualdades se usan con mucha frecuencia, y parte de la razón es que a menudo nos importa más
la distancia traza en última instancia, porque tiene una interpretación natural que se conecta con la discriminación de estados cuánticos
pero la Fidelidad tiene tantas propiedades asombrosas que en general es la más fácil de trabajar, y mientras estemos en la esquina superior izquierda de
la región gris, que es donde solemos encontrarnos, no perdemos demasiado al convertir entre la Fidelidad y la distancia traza. Así que esas
estas son algunas de las propiedades de la Fidelidad, hay muchas más, pero es un buen comienzo y esperemos que la lista sea
útil para empezar a desarrollar cierta intuición sobre la Fidelidad. Aquí hay un buen ejemplo de cómo
podemos conectar la Fidelidad con las mediciones no destructivas. Es un hecho muy útil conocido como el Lema de la medición suave
Supón que tenemos un sistema x, un estado de X representado por una matriz de densidad rho, y una medición sobre el sistema X
descrita por una colección de matrices semidefinidas positivas. Supongamos que uno de los resultados de la medición es muy probable que
aparezca si realizáramos la medición sobre el estado rho. Para simplificar, supongamos
que es el resultado Z Z el que es muy probable y, en particular, supongamos que este resultado aparece con
probabilidad mayor que 1 menos Epsilon para algún valor pequeño de Epsilon. En realidad no necesitamos especificar Epsilon,
es solo un número real positivo pequeño. Ahora bien, hemos descrito nuestra medición como si fuera una medición destructiva,
pero sabemos por la lección anterior que podríamos implementar esta medición de forma no destructiva y, concretamente, podríamos hacerlo como
vimos en nuestra discusión del teorema de Neymar, y funciona así: cada resultado a aparece con
probabilidad igual a la traza de PA por rho y, condicionado a obtener ese resultado, el estado de X cambia. En
particular, en el caso de que obtengamos el resultado probable cero, el estado se convierte en la raíz cuadrada de p 0 por rho por la raíz cuadrada de p 0,
todo normalizado para que obtengamos una matriz de densidad. Y lo que nos dice el lema de la medición suave es que en este caso,
es decir, cuando obtenemos el resultado probable de la medición, el estado que obtenemos no habrá cambiado mucho respecto al
original y, en particular, la Fidelidad al cuadrado será necesariamente mayor que 1 menos
Epsilon. Esto es genial porque es completamente general: no hemos dicho nada sobre la medición ni
el estado, excepto que uno de los resultados es muy probable. Por eso el Lema se puede aplicar en
muchos contextos diferentes en los que queramos verificar algo sobre un estado cuántico sin perturbarlo demasiado. Veamos cómo podemos demostrarlo:
en su mayor parte, es un asunto bastante sencillo de calcular la Fidelidad entre los estados anterior y posterior a la medición.
Podemos hacerlo usando la definición original y, normalmente, eso podría dejarnos con una fórmula complicada, pero
en este caso tenemos suerte porque lo que está dentro de la raíz cuadrada exterior es en realidad el cuadrado de una matriz que
resulta ser semidefinida positiva, lo que hace que calcular la raíz cuadrada sea trivial. Ahora podemos usar la propiedad cíclica
de la traza junto con la linealidad de la traza para simplificar nuestra expresión, como se muestra en la pantalla. Nota, por cierto, que estas son
todas igualdades, así que no hemos aproximado nada hasta este punto, realmente solo estamos simplificando. Pero ahora sí necesitamos una
desigualdad porque queremos eliminar esa raíz cuadrada en el numerador, y podemos hacerlo si estamos dispuestos a conformarnos con una cota inferior. Y si
te interesan los detalles de esta parte, puedes obtener la desigualdad con bastante facilidad considerando una descomposición espectral de p
0. Los valores propios de p 0 tienen que estar entre 0 y 1, eso siempre es cierto para matrices que describen
mediciones. Y una vez que sabemos eso, la desigualdad se deduce casi directamente del hecho de que tomar la raíz cuadrada de
un número entre 0 y 1 solo puede hacerlo más grande. Otra forma de decirlo es que elevar al cuadrado un número entre 0 y
1 solo puede hacerlo más pequeño. Ahora podemos simplificar un poco más y obtenemos la raíz
cuadrada de la traza de p 0 por rho. Finalmente, elevando al cuadrado ambos lados y
sustituyendo nuestra cota sobre la probabilidad obtenemos lo que queremos. Así que la fórmula de la Fidelidad
no es la más bonita ni la más fácil de usar del mundo, pero aquí funciona bastante
bien. Para concluir la lección, veremos el teorema de Uhlmann, que es un hecho fundamental sobre la Fidelidad que
la conecta con la noción de purificación. Lo que dice el teorema en términos simples es que la Fidelidad entre dos cualesquiera
estados cuánticos es igual al máximo producto interno en valor absoluto entre dos purificaciones de esos
estados. Con un poco más de detalle: supón que rho y sigma son matrices de densidad para algún sistema X, y supón que Y es un
sistema que tiene al menos tantos estados clásicos como X y, por lo tanto, tenemos garantizado que ambos estados tienen purificaciones que son
vectores de estado cuántico de XY. Podemos entonces expresar la implicación del teorema en forma de la ecuación
mostrada en la pantalla: la Fidelidad entre rho y sigma es igual al máximo valor absoluto del producto interno
entre F y S, tomando el máximo sobre todos los fi y S que purifican rho y sigma
respectivamente. Así que vamos a limpiar esto y trabajar con el enunciado matemático preciso a partir de ahora. Lo que haremos ahora es demostrar
el teorema, pero primero vale la pena tomarse un momento para apreciar que nos ofrece una forma bastante intuitiva de pensar sobre la
Fidelidad. También resulta ser bastante útil en sí mismo, por ejemplo para demostrar cosas aún más interesantes sobre
la Fidelidad. Para demostrarlo, empezaremos con descomposiciones espectrales de nuestras matrices de densidad.
Sin sorpresas ahí. Una vez que tenemos las descomposiciones espectrales, es fácil encontrar
dos purificaciones específicas de estos estados. Pero aquí vamos a usar un
truco. Fíjate que en ambos casos no tenemos un vector de base estándar como segundo factor tensorial, como teníamos antes en la
lección, sino que tenemos el mismo vector que en el primer factor tensorial, excepto que tiene una barra encima, y
eso significa el conjugado complejo entrada a entrada de esos vectores. Así que, en otras palabras, básicamente estamos tomando una
segunda copia de los vectores propios, pero tomamos el conjugado complejo de cada entrada. Veremos por qué hacemos eso en unos
momentos, pero no es nada obvio que debamos hacerlo, y por eso lo llamamos un
truco. En cualquier caso, estas son purificaciones de rho y sigma respectivamente, y eso es cierto en virtud
del hecho de que nuestros vectores propios son ortonormales y, por lo tanto, también lo son sus conjugados complejos entrada a entrada. Ahora podemos aplicar la
equivalencia unitaria de purificaciones, que nos dice que toda purificación de nuestros dos estados puede obtenerse aplicando
una operación unitaria al sistema que se traza. Para las elecciones específicas de purificaciones que
acabamos de hacer, las operaciones unitarias no tienen que ser las mismas para las dos purificaciones,
por supuesto. Así que aquí usamos la letra U para la primera y la letra V para la segunda.
El punto es que toda purificación de nuestros dos estados puede escribirse como tenemos en la pantalla, para
alguna elección de operaciones unitarias u y v. Y ahora podemos tomar la expresión
del teorema y simplificar. Si sustituimos nuestras expresiones para F y S y simplificamos un poco,
obtenemos la expresión que se muestra aquí en la pantalla. Hay un par de pasos ahí que no he mostrado en detalle,
así que ya sabes qué hacer si quieres trabajarlos. Pero déjame mencionar que la razón por la que elegimos las purificaciones como lo hicimos
fue para permitir que este producto interno se simplifique exactamente de esta manera. En particular, pusimos los conjugados complejos
ahí para poder, en efecto, dar vuelta los productos internos en el segundo factor tensorial y obtener la forma específica
que tenemos aquí. Ya casi terminamos. Ahora podemos usar la propiedad cíclica de la traza junto
con las descomposiciones espectrales con las que empezamos para obtener esta expresión. Y en este punto podemos
emplear una de las formas alternativas de expresar la Fidelidad usando la norma traza, y
listo. Ciertamente hay detalles ahí que pasé por alto muy rápidamente, y es el tipo de demostración que
realmente necesitas trabajar tú mismo para comprenderla del todo. Pero esperemos que esto te dé la idea básica
y, como siempre, puedes encontrar más detalles en el contenido escrito de la lección, que está enlazado en el vídeo.
descripción. Y eso es el final de la lección, que ha tratado sobre purificaciones, Fidelidad y las conexiones entre ellas. También es
el final de la unidad, que ha tratado sobre la formulación general de la información cuántica. Espero que te unas a mí para
la cuarta y última unidad de la serie, que trata sobre corrección de errores cuánticos. Gracias por ver.